y
[Música]
a finales de julio el presidente andrés
manuel lópez obrador tenía la intención
de celebrar las fiestas patrias con por
lo menos 500 asistentes a la plancha del
zócalo capitalino en sana distancia sin
embargo mes y medio después las
condiciones actuales de la pandemia no
lo permitieron por lo que por primera
vez se llevó a cabo el grito de
independencia sin público asistente al
zócalo tuvo lugar un espectáculo de
pirotecnia y se encendió una flama que
se denominó de la esperanza lo mismo
ocurrió en las 16 alcaldías de la ciudad
de mexico donde el festejo fue virtual
así como en los estados de la república
asimismo el desfile militar el
tradicional desfile del 16 de septiembre
se llevó a cabo con un número reducido
de soldados duró menos tiempo que las
ocasiones anteriores y se otorgó un
reconocimiento al personal médico que
está en la lucha contra el kobe 19
[Música]
el gobierno de nicaragua realizó durante
el fin de semana pasado diversas
actividades por festejos patrios
aglomerando a cientos de personas en
todas partes del país principalmente a
estudiantes de colegios públicos en
nicaragua quienes se vieron obligado a
salir a las calles de sus municipios y
ciudades a realizar festejos
tradicionales esto en medio de la
emergencia ocasionada por el coronavirus
esta semana en donde se conmemora la
independencia de nicaragua el gobierno
también decretó feriado nacional durante
toda la semana para los trabajadores del
estado y exoneró del impuesto al valor
agregado al sector turismo como parte de
un plan de reactivación económica la
unidad sindical magisterial denunció que
este tipo de actividades pone en riesgo
de contagio principalmente a docentes y
estudiantes de todo el país
[Música]
en chiles sabemos cuando se acercan las
patillas porque todos los edificios se
visten con la bandera chilena como este
que tenemos a nuestras espaldas es
obligatorio por ley que todos los
edificios incluidos las viviendas dónde
en banderas chilenas en estas fechas
bajo penas de multa si estás sin embargo
serán unas fiestas patrias muy
diferentes marcadas por la pandemia el
gobierno avanzado a su plan font de ate
en casa que trata de promocionar una
celebración íntima de estas fechas y que
no ha estado el centro de la polémica
pues si bien en un principio se permitía
invitar a cinco personas adicionales al
núcleo familiar en todas las comunas de
chile estuvo de ser revertido a aquellas
comunas que no se encuentran bajo
cuarentena ante el temor de que los
contagios se expendan masivamente en
estas fechas marcadamente sociales serán
unas fiestas patrias diferentes en las
que los chilenos no podrán acudir a las
fondas lugares públicos donde se
comparten asados bebidas y también se ve
bailar la cueca el baile nacional que
normalmente llena las calles en estas
fechas unas fechas muy queridas por los
chilenos esperadas durante todo el año
que marcan la conmemoración de la
primera junta nacional que dio lugar a
la independencia del país
[Música]